yesterday was supposed to be a
celebratory day and then we got tragic
news about Kobe Bryant and everything
changed in a second
that's Ellen DeGeneres holding back
tears while paying tribute to NBA legend
Kobe Bryant life is short and it's
fragile and we don't know how many
birthdays we have so just we don't want
to have a birthday to celebrate just
celebrate life Kobe and his 13 year old
daughter Gianna were among nine people
killed in a helicopter accident on
Sunday if you haven't told someone you
love them do it now do it tell people
you love them but Ellen wasn't the only
talk-show host to honor the late great
Los Angeles Lakers player Kobe was such
a life force so strong and creative and
inspired that in my head I thought that
he was gonna live forever Jimmy Fallon
opened his show on Monday recalling how
he first met Kobe at a party when they
were both young and relatively unknown I
met Kobe when he was 17 and I was 21 he
was a rookie on the Lakers and I was
just starting out in the comedy scene in
LA we were at a party and we didn't know
anyone at the party Jimmy got emotional
saying they were friends ever since when
we'd run into each other over the years
we'd laugh about that night that we
first met
for all the good things that happen
since and we laugh about how much fun it
was great kids all the stupid mistake
she's made trying to figure out how to
be good dads and the Tonight Show host
explained how we can all honor Kobe's
legacy I think I knew Kobe enough to
know that he rose to any challenge by
digging deeper and getting back to work
so let's honor Kobe gianna and the other
lives that were lost yesterday by
following his example love your family
love your teammates and outwork everyone
else in the gym Jimmy Kimmel opted out
of having a live studio audience on
Monday going forward with a comedy show
didn't feel right considering what
happened yesterday so I'd like to just
speak to you directly and dedicated his
entire show to Kobe he was a bright
light and that's how I want to remember
him he was on the show 15 times we had
many fun and interesting conversations
and tonight we are going to share some
of those to remember him Conan O'Brien
also played back some of his favorite
moments with Kobe over the years and
said this about the type of guest he was
whenever he was on our show he was a joy
to talk with and he always had the
audience in the palm of his hand that's
the guy that I've been thinking about
these past 24 hours and it's that memory
that I would like to share with you
tonight James Corden reflected on the
last time Kobe stopped by his show
following his 2016 retirement from the
NBA he couldn't stop talking about how
excited he was to have all this free
time to devote to his family and to
coach his daughters and I remember
loving hearing him talk like that a man
who had achieved so much in his life was
just so he was so excited just to get to
be a dad for a while
ESPN's Elle Duncan echoed James's
sentiment on SportsCenter praising Kobe
for being a proud dad his third daughter
Bianca was about a year and a half old
at the time so I asked if he wanted more
children and he said that his wife
Vanessa really wanted to try again for a
boy but was sort of jokingly concerned
that it would be on
girl and I was like four girls are you
joking like what would you think how
would you feel and without hesitation he
said I would have five more girls if I
could I'm a girl dad Elle who met Kobe
when she was eight months pregnant with
a daughter of her own broke down in
tears I suppose that the only small
source of comfort for me is knowing that
he died doing what he loved the most a
big dad being a girl dad ET will
continue to be here to bring you all the
latest on this tragic story until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now